gloss pour ça en anglais courge courge
c'est une bonne
plus proche à peu près aussi loin de ta
bouche parfait ok un
deux trois
Y et si nous nous asseyions tous et
parlions et énumérions toutes les choses que vous
trouveriez dans une cuisine, nous pourrions en trouver 30
ou  40 choses
et chacune de ces choses sont enregistrées,
dactylographiées et euh mises dans la base de données
et elles sont également alignées sur l'enregistrement audio.
Cass Cass génial, ils sonnent
bien brillant pour ça dans l'histoire de squash squash anglaise, n'est-ce
pas et vous savez que c'est là-
bas en
single
lang  euh, la technologie nous a aidé à exploiter les
boissons et nous a aidé à sauvegarder les langues
plus rapidement que jamais, euh par exemple,
nous pouvons maintenant créer un dictionnaire euh pour une
communauté à partir de zéro, euh en 12 mois, alors qu'avant, il
fallait 20 ans pour pouvoir
le faire, et c'est donc  incroyable et
c'est super important, cela nous permet de
servir les langues euh rapidement et de construire
l'infrastructure dont elles ont besoin pour
pouvoir survivre en faisant
avancer [Musique
] [
Musique]
[Musique]
Je suis un deuxième apprenant comme le bronzage est mon
deuxième  langue que j'apprends et donc
je suis vraiment
excité pour cela parce que euh, il y a tellement
de lacunes que j'ai dans mon propre
parcours d'apprentissage des langues, donc avoir ce
dictionnaire va vraiment m'aider à
en apprendre davantage et à élargir mon
vocabulaire J'aime l'
aspect technologique, vous savez, je pense que nous, vous
savez, nous devons faire attention à la manière dont
les choses sont gérées, vous savez
comment elles sont distribuées et qui a le
contrôle sur certaines propriétés du
langage, mais je  je pense vraiment que c'est d'une
grande aide pour la plupart des tribus,
nous avions juste un dictionnaire très rudimentaire
avec seulement quelques milliers de
mots, nous voulions un dictionnaire qui
représente un vocabulaire adulte, je veux dire un
locuteur parfaitement fluide de la
langue absolo, maintenant nous avons cela non seulement nous  je
l'ai, c'est sous forme imprimée mais c'est
en ligne et nous pouvons entendre chaque mot
ou phrase prononcé à la fois par une femme et un
homme, ce qui est un énorme avantage en
seulement quelques
années [de musique]